it was emotional III was you know and
again this has nothing to do with what
happens in the plot regardless of what
happens in the plot I would still feel a
real sense of emotional swell I keep
telling everybody they should move on
some do bananas it is the culmination of
ten years and twenty one twenty two
movies are something like that it's it's
a huge chunk of my life and the
experiences I've had the friendships
I've made mean a lot to me and to here
you know your raft on the last movie
just it it shook me up yeah you got the
shield did you get the suit no I've been
asking for the suit I'll get two I'll go
I'll get you can't get this I'll get
this they gave me the shield to give me
the cowl and on this one I'm saying come
on guys finish the set give me the whole
shipment what would you do with the suit
have you got it
ah you know I'm sure my buddies would
you know I'm sure it'd be more fun for
my friends and for me but I don't know I
probably just you know the real question
is which suit what I want what song
would you want Civil War well that's the
bit I don't know maybe maybe maybe maybe
Winter Soldier was it tough for you on
the last day or were you just like okay
let's all go around let's kiss and hug
uh no it was tough it was I mean it's
been a huge part of my life and I love
these guys I also you know you never
know what Wow he learned it and then you
just find out he didn't know this is
gonna work Steve
I know it is because I don't know what
I'm gonna do if it doesn't is there
anybody in particular that you'll miss
no no of course well I mean obviously
everybody but but I really we never we
never really fall out of contact
though at least the main the the og sex
I mean like the g6 the the that group we
have a text chain and you know from the
time we're at the time we start pressed
we're always oh what is the og six Oh
like know what is always texting like
crazy it's inappropriate
yeah it's fun it's a bunch of people set
together yeah I mean it's just it's of
people but it's mostly like I miss you
guys so much
and then everyone cha-cha I know because
everyone goes out to do other jobs and
you know when you start other jobs every
movie is gonna have a different vibe and
a dynamic and and sometimes those vibes
are great and wonderful and sometimes
they're not what you you know what you
had and and it's it's easy to kind of be
like you know what I'm really missing my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]